everyone we're about to talk about Lego
Star Wars the Skywalker saga with Jordan
here actually get to see the game at e3
yes I think I played a lot of these Lego
Star Wars games it's not the same thing
again is it yeah so I went in completely
thinking that it was going to be just a
remaster of the old games but it's
completely brand-new so every single
level from like the old Lego Star Wars
games has just been completely
redesigned and it's not even a linear
game like the old ones where it's an
open world now open galaxy so the levels
are different because they have you know
released these Lego games kind of
piecemeal you know put them in different
eras and episodes and stuff but it's new
F so yeah they've decided to just create
a brand new game from the ground up so
some of the characters do different
things than they did in the past some of
them run differently some of them attack
differently there's a combo system now
different levels different cutscenes
it's completely new if you've played the
old games and you love them you will
enjoy this one because it's a brand new
experience ok and I think one of the
interesting things that you brought up
there was it's not linear right so hey
that worked because it's supposed to be
looking at the like the 9 movies and the
mainland saga right yeah so from the
title screen you have the option of
choosing any of the 9 main line movie so
Phantom Menace attack of the clones etc
etc you can tackle them in any order
that you want when you click on an
episode so let's say a new hope for
example it recreates the galaxy at large
like the new hope so if you decide to
fly to Tatooine then Luke's aunt and
uncle would be there their house would
be in very nice condition and you get to
explore Tatooine during that setting
however if you decided to pick Return of
the Jedi and you flew to Tatooine then
in that instance like aunt and uncle are
dead sorry for anyone who hasn't seen
episode boilers boilers but and there's
like tumbleweeds going through and that
entire area is completely barren but if
you travel a ways throughout Tatooine in
each of these planets its kind of
similar to the New York setting in Lego
Marvel superheroes where it's very
open-world you get to explore it you
could find a Javas barge
for example which wouldn't necessarily
be there
episode 4 because job isn't like a main
character in that instance yet I get it
so for what happens with with some of
those planets that you know have nothing
that happened in them within those
movies so for example end all like you
go to can you go to end or if you're
doing like episode 7 or what's what like
say they seem to imply that there is a
set number of planets for like each of
the three trilogies at play so you might
not necessarily be able to go to like
Nabu for example in Episode four even
though it was technically there for the
very beginning of that movie it would
probably just be exclusively for the
prequel okay prequel movies but they
didn't give me an exact answer on that
so I have it could possibly be that you
could just explore any of the planets
throughout the nine different movies as
as you see them okay there's been like
very many of these Lego games and you
know the the gameplay for it has been
fairly standard I've been trying to add
anything new or is it still you know
like the so very kid-friendly co-op like
combat like puzzle type stuff it's
pretty similar to what you would expect
there is a combo system now so it kind
of measures like if you press the X
button two times then Luke will swing
his lightsaber in this way but if you
press the X button three times then you
press the B button after that you would
sling swing his lightsaber in a slightly
different manner so there's a bit of a
combo system in that regards but at the
end of the day if you just smashed that
X button then you're going to cut
through enemies regardless or shoot them
with a blaster the riddles and puzzles
have made a return as well although
they're a bit more fun to actually
complete now you unlock khyber bricks
we're doing it and you now use those
khyber bricks to pay for new ships and
new ship upgrades which you can use and
the new ship space battles that occur in
the open galaxy not just as exciting
tell me yes so it's like actual so like
dog fighting is all right yeah so now
whenever you spawn into the game so if
you spawned like into episode 4 and your
first mission is to go to Tatooine for
Luke to engage with old Ben you actually
have to fly to
Tatooine and maybe you own the
Millennium Falcon so you're flying in
the Millennium Falcon and maybe on your
way to Tatooine you run into an imperial
star destroyer fighting a rebel frigate
and it's just a space battle going on
that's cool yeah you can either just
decide to skip it and just go straight
to the planets assert your story mission
to do some side quest or you can fly
into the space battle it kind of plays
out similarly to the 2005 battlefront
two space battles there's just a bunch
of ships flying around you get to side
with whichever one you want and try to
like take out their drag not but but
it's not on Rails though right like you
have some freedom yeah you're just
within freely flying around even when
you're going to the planet you can
freely fly around in space so it's not
on Rails yeah completely open it's an
open world game okay no one of the when
the key features of I think the Lego
games has always been its humor no its
charm and you know how would you know
tries to reconceptualize you know like
the events that you know and try and put
a funny spin on it yeah like are they
still doing that with this one they're
not recycling jokes are they know they
are not recycling jokes that they have
plenty of new ones uh one of my
favorites is that c-3po can now like
divide himself into piece distance he's
always falling apart in the movies and
you can move independently some of the
droids that you encounter like the gonk
droid that kind of goes like boo boo boo
boo Boop and all the movies c-3po can
actually talk to those droids and you
find out that they're saying like I have
no nose so I can't smell the trash okay
and I'm trying to find the trash
compactor can you help me and he'll like
wander around and if he acts and like
trips on a rock or encounters an enemy
falls down he'll just repeatedly be like
help help help help me get up and it's
just this adorable little droid and you
finally get to figure out what they are
saying and then there's just random
funny moments - like death Vader cutting
off Luke's hand realizing his mistake
and being like no you can have one of my
robot hands instead I actually find that
droid story very sad and I cannot smell
which is my main function okay so this
sounds very exciting what is this game
actually coming out Jordan I don't
believe that they've given a release
date for the Skywalker saga but I
imagine it has to be either late this
year or early next year considering that
Episode nine is a part of the story and
I don't think that they want to spoil
that for me
maybe you know excite to find all this
out would be GameSpot where you can find
a lot more evening coverage
you
[Music]